twice i'm thinking the fact they played
in a death match surprised by this
decision from artemiev we saw that
magnus just contemplating that how to
reply he chooses one of the most
flexible moves against the english
opening bringing the black knight out
and
so this is the last final that we will
see in the 2021 tour all right and
meanwhile magnus plays copycat he's just
gone for this symmetrical pawn structure
symmetrical system right now it cost him
a bit of time and the viewers at home
might be wondering why did magnus spend
a minute and a half on move two but
that's because black has so many choices
so many different setups and
you definitely have to choose a type of
style here remember artemis he's not
going to try and beat you from the
opening he's just trying to guide the
middle game and end game into his type
of
type of position so that's why magnus
he's going to pause a few times in these
early stages just thinking what is going
to make artemis most uncomfortable ideas
here for white and now we see our temmie
of just taking a pause and not going for
the one of uh one of the moves you
mentioned ivanka playing a different
approach pushing this pawn instead that
it's impossible to remember all your
games first of all but also it's uh
impossible to kind of guess all of your
opponent's possible replies that's why
we see the few pauses here and there
it's not one of those types of positions
where everything will get traded really
direct attacks uh at the moment it is
very much about building up and both
sides are built up by occupying the
center with their pawns some pawns in
the center okay no he just waits this is
also very flexible carlson pretty much
the same thought that's going through
magnus's head both players they're
playing this game in their mind so far
rather than on the actual board but we
do finally see a decision from artemiev
he did go for a pawn trade he pushed
upon and now this last move by black it
is the most ambitious locking down
gaining space on this left flank and
possible diagonal and there we go
artemis plays it the most natural move
in the position if you can back that up
then it's going to be a bit dangerous so
okay magnus brings his bishop out and as
far as i know this last movie is a bit
of a rare one black has other options
yep so white's bishop just kind of
challenging for this dark square
diagonal very sensible developing a
piece what do you think and then of
course sometimes you know looking over
if if there's something to check but and
the computer would say david will play
like this but isn't that kind of what
the play magnus app is doing though it's
mimicking magnus at 10 years old his
playing style and also now at 30 years
old now this position has been analyzed
before and
magnus is reacting in the way that uh
the analysis went so magnus he's very
familiar with these types of patterns
and even if he didn't i mean remember
the exact move order he's found a way to
get into something he knows and he's
been trying he's pushed pawns he's now
attacking white's knight in the centre
of the board with this last rook move as
well he's forcing artemis to make big
decisions at an early stage black hole
recapture that's right this has happened
actually okay and in that game magnus
immediately actually he's
he played exactly like artemyev so he
challenged black's pawn wedge there on
the left side and duboff answered with
bishop takes knight and now we have a
deviation it's fine but he has to deal
with these uh instant moves coming okay
he does trade and magnus instantly again
bringing his bishop out attacking this
pawn there's so much more interest that
still hasn't been fully worked out that
hasn't been explored and that's what
magnus is trying to use against artemiev
and okay meanwhile white's queen has
just
kind of slid to the side black's bishop
has captured a pawn as expected and now
white's rook is under fire from that
black bishop so it has to move
the clock is just up in our face all the
time yeah
you've got to tweet us by using those
three hashtags you're basically winning
becoming a better chess player exactly
and you know what better way you're
using technology to do it and we have
seen a trade of pieces on the board okay
so a bit of a committal trade there by
magnus carson usually we talk about the
bishop pair quite a lot having two
bishops is better than having a bishop
at night in general but here the pawn
structure in the center is blocked
there's lots of closed lines but that
white bishop the white light squared
bishop in front of the king if it ever
disappears if it ever trades itself off
will just leave too many light squared
weaknesses and okay magnus is saying you
didn't trade you still have your light
square bishop but i'm going to attack
you anyway and he's throwing harry the h
born down the board black's pawn
marching
is just going to try and loosen up the
position around white's king
psychologically it's probably stronger
than it is objectively and that's all
that magnus needs right now and that has
also forced white's queen to step back
so that white queen is eyeing up a pawn
on this diagonal and magnus will just
deal with that pawn bring that black
queen out okay he does push the pawn
and okay magnus making a face there uh
raising his eyebrows that is strange uh
why why won't he take it instead
yeah you wouldn't really take that pawn
because you know we talked about king
safety and it's very important for king
to have a very compact pawn shield
around it if you start opening up lines
against your king then it makes it
easier to attack bypassing that pawn
trade it does come at the price of
loosening up white structure so white
does have weaknesses that black will
soon go after meanwhile just a couple
important pushes on the other flank by
both sides
yeah just
slightly improving their pawn structure
but magnus now is gonna switch his
attentions fully i think towards the
white king wow i mean the black pieces
they're just so far off the board
they're kind of inching forward yeah and
this is a scary situation and uh it's
not just the pieces inching forward the
bar is also going that way as well one
of the black rooks into the game he does
this
he lifts that black rook up it doesn't
look like it's going anywhere on the
line that it stands so he's going to
swing it across and go for the white
king if possible meanwhile artemis also
improving one of the white rooks yep and
that's how
the question is how is magnus gonna
start improving and converting his
advantage which is the other minute
dynamic into something a little bit more
concrete and he comes out with the queen
yeah meanwhile quite a commitment move
again from artemia he's pushed the pawn
forward but pawns don't move backwards
yes that pawn is attacking the black
queen forcing her to retreat but look at
the black knight now that has become an
outpost the square it sits on it can
never be challenged by a white pawn
anymore see a scenario where
i mean somehow the queen's come off and
i don't know white's rooks get active
and maybe white has enough counterplay
to make it just feels like there's a lot
of pressure yeah in here there's a lot
of tension and i don't see any trades
happening anytime soon how is white ever
going to trade off black strong bishop
for example afar so maybe across some
diagonals she doesn't need to that's why
he shifts the queen to this diagonal so
the black queen on a dark square
diagonal might have some influence later
on um you don't necessarily have to
attack from the front with queens maybe
you can attack from the side activate
his remaining passive piece that black
rook in the corner and that's why
artemis is speeding up the game if he
can pushing a pawn forward attacking the
black rook we'll just move that rook
retreat
and uh tamiya actually playing a very
neat
queen retreat and attacking that pawn on
the h4 square even moving the knight
back to an outpost but okay first he
does keep that pawn alive he brings his
queen back and he's going to reroute her
i'll tell me immediately going one point
up not hesitating being materialistic
because it's what he has to do you might
as well suffer for something but now i
expect to see magnus play a move such as
bringing the queen forward for the
position
he sacrifices another pawn magnus
carlsen offering to go two pawns down
i'll tell you have said yes please yeah
yes please i'm i think you're bluffing
but magnus
will he bluff i don't think that's world
champion style to bluff he's brought his
queen out now so he's two pawns down as
black but look at these two pieces they
are extremely strong and they're the
best attacking combo remember queen and
knight together and let's ignore the
evaluation bar for now it's going back
towards the center black is two pawns
down but the fact that the computer says
okay it's still roughly balanced means
that black sacrifice has been justified
and if black gets more time there's
actually quite a big threat in the
position if the white rook moves across
for example then the black knight can
just step back and this would be a
double attack yeah when when a king is
open that means it's vulnerable to
attack and it means that it's all about
who has the dynamic initiative who has
the momentum and david highlighted
really critical
knight maneuver and
okay okay magnus doesn't go for it
switching his attention he's trying to
conquer this open sea line so he's
trying to get rid of white's most active
rook and if we do see a trade of rooks
his other black rook is maybe going to
try and infiltrate from the side so he's
tied down white actually to the defense
of several pawns and now he's switching
switching focus and he's oh hang on a
second hang on i was just gonna say this
wasn't possible because i was thinking
oh
i'm too excited david i need you to whoa
yeah look at the bar black has actually
blocked up this line now blocked up the
sea line so white queen under fire from
that bishop and because the connection
between the white rooks has been broken
black is also threatening to capture one
of white's rooks with his own rook so a
double threat now for magnus carlsen and
i think you're right ivanka this is
gonna cost white material how are you
gonna save the queen and your rook at
the same time you either have to give up
the queen for a couple of rooks but the
queen here is by far the most important
piece are we gonna see it on the board
okay i was gonna say maybe you could
sacrifice a root for bishop as well but
now white queen has fallen white gained
two rooks in the process but look at the
white king without the white queen how
are you gonna defend it that king looks
so
horrible i mean first of all you know
white would really love to put the rooks
on the top rope but they can't do that
because queen takes pawn is now in the
air and now the queen and the bishop
have coordinated for an attack on the g4
pawn and this is it when it comes to
peace positions with peace imbalances is
all about king safety and white king i'm
sorry it's got no cover it's doomed yeah
look at that evaluation it confirms your
assessment completely there ivanka white
king
i mean it would love a night around it
would love a queen around to defend but
no those pieces don't exist and now all
that black needs to do is move his
bishop and on this g line it's disaster
it's actually checkmate in a few moves
now black's bishop coming to attack that
white bishop which is pinned and
checkmate comes
i'll tell you if resigns wow what a
start to the final you guys after 36
moves and only playing for 39 minutes
magnus carlsen with the black pieces
wins the first game